[Musique]
on a le plaisir d'accueillir encore une
fois jamais de bertrand bonjour madame
bertrand
bonsoir vous savez que vous êtes à
l'origine du fourrage est donc allé voir
à votre cerveau studio il ya deux mois
et vous m'aviez demandé madame bertrand
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour
améliorer le sort des personnes âgées
qui dit bafouent leur demander ce qu'ils
veulent et s'affilie comme ça le
lendemain ou le surlendemain il y avait
la fondation de fondation la fondation
jasmin roy et sophie desmarais et la
fondation de sembler gériatrique de
montréal qui m'appelle dire bon on le
fait on le fait en boule d'or on le fait
alors j'ai participé hier à poser les
questions
je voulais vraiment savoir ce qu'il
voulait et puis j'ai les réponses c'est
merveilleux c'est merveilleux
certainement on va les données on va
faire on a préparé un petit tableau on
peut pas tout présenté le sondage met
les grandes lignes il ya les deux tiers
qui ne veulent pas qu'ils ont une
crainte 62 % craignent de devoir
déménager en ch à celle des mois aussi
tous faire de ce fait plaisir pourquoi
parce qu'on a la pandémie on a vu on a
vu une personne qui restaient dans leur
leurs couches qui n'était pas la vie qui
on s'en occupait pas on est tombé devant
on a compensé jamais que ça existait on
ne pensait jamais qu'on pouvait traiter
ceux qui nous ont mis au monde qui ont
fait la nation de cette façon là alors
on l'est on l'a on veut pas y aller
or le ciel tu es faut le dire vraiment
la bête est faible faut le dire vraiment
il faut que le le le mon dieu j'ai perdu
parce que ça vient de marquer ma patrie
brest on est à l'essai de ces entrevues
leur festin on a deux points se revoir
ah oui alors alors alors alors il est ce
que je disais je donc ils ne veulent pas
se retrouver
dites vous
et pendant 75 % souhaitent une
bonification des soins de santé à la
police et à domicile ils demandent pas
grand chose quand vous savez quand ils
disent ils vos attentes vis-à-vis
gouvernement il demande un peu d'argent
pour l'aide au logement
c'est tout moi je pensais qu'ils
demanderaient vraiment beaucoup de
choses non ils demandent juste rester
chez eux alors qu'on s'y par la
psychologie que le déménagement
incertaine art c'est un des des racines
et des versements déracinement merci
déracinement et que déracinement ça fait
mal alors ils veulent rester
il veut garder cathy quand ils parlent
qu'ils veulent l'autonomie c'est à 92%
ils veulent qu'on les respecte ils
veulent qu'on leur demande conseil ils
veulent qu'on les écoute quand ils
disent qu'ils veulent rester à la maison
qu'on leur construise pas d'autres elle
grosse maison ils veulent rester chez
eux avec de l'aide et ça c'est
intéressant parce que on le dit depuis
quoi 25-30 a eu des rapports ce rapport
il faut augmenter les soins à domicile
ont eu une annonce récemment mais
c'était 100 millions le sûr je pense
cinq ans six antennes gotteland
nettement alors il faut s'apprendre
révolution alors votre sondage peut-être
amené de l'eau au moulin alsa soin de
nice est la priorité numéro un
priorité numéro un ils veulent pas
partir de chez eux même si leur chez eux
et et petit mince it 2 me ce sont tes
affaires que tana dedans c'était à faire
quand il parle de respect et on ne nous
respecte pas on ne nous on
on est vraiment dans cette société de
consommation
on est vraiment des prêts à jeter des
prêts comment ça s'appelle ce qu'on
annonce brawn aux appareils des idées
des choses qui ne servent plus on
pourrait mettre un entrepôt
mais pour les vieux est-ce que
une bande le sondage est fait j'espère
et quoi d'abord vous allez en parler
vous en parlait ici ailleurs
j'espère que les personnes âgées d'abord
je pense à lui bondi on eût dit pour
monde on n'est qu'à 6 qu'ils veulent
pour leurs enfants
ils veulent que leurs enfants leurs
attentes' pour que les enfants prennent
soin d'eux ils veulent que il veut que
les enfants lui redonne un peu de temps
qu'ils puissent borloo si on demanderiez
on est orgueilleux on demanderions ni
fier on veut juste un peu des deux et
qu'on nous respecte qu'on nous traite
comme des êtres humains et non pas des
prêts qui ne servent plus
janette bertrand c'est toujours un
plaisir de vous parler merci beaucoup
merci à la prochaine on va sur paraître
la prochaine fois peut-être en vrai en
vrai d'accord merci a bientot c'est à
bientôt pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit